الكل يعلم ان غزه تقبع فوق شبكه انفاق
تستخدمها المقاومه في تنفيذ عملياتها ضد
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اصلا حماس بنفسها
تقول لدينا 500 كيل متر من الانفاق وليست
جديده بالمناسبه قبل سبع سنوات صرح
اسماعيل هنيه انهم صنعوا ضعف انفاق فيتنام
البالغ طولها
2 كيلومترا
تقريبا طبعا هي بالاصل ارض محاصره ليس
لديهم شيء سوى بناء
الانفاق بعد 52 يوما من التوغل البري لجيش
الاحتلال بريا في
غزه يعلن الجيش عن اكتشاف نفق اين في شمال
قطاع غزه يقول انه الاضخم طوله 4
كيلومترات وعمقه 50 مترا ويتفرع الى عده
خطوط جانبيه ويتسع لعبور السيارات يعني
ضخم تقول اسرائيل ان النفق يقع على بعد
400 متر فقط من بعبر ايريز شديد التحصين
وبالقرب من قاعده ايريز
العسكريه يبدو ان اسرائيل متفاجئه من
عثورها على هذا النفق هل تفاجات انتم من
تفاجا منكم اصلا لو سالت هذا الطفل في غزه
عن منزل ابو فلان الفلاني سيقول لك عمو
تعرف النفق ضع النفق خلفك وعد اول يمين
الثاني الثالث تجد باب لونه اخضر اقرع
الجرس اركب اي باص او ميكرو باص في غزه
ستجد السائق يصيح لركاب نفق اريس حدا
نازل امشي في سيارتك ضع جوجل مابس مع
الصوت ستجد المرشد الصوتي يقول لك اكمل
الطريق بمحاذاه النفق ثم انعطف يسارا لا
يوجد احد متفاجئ من كل الغزاويين بوجود
النفق من كل العرب تقريبا اسرائيل وحدها
من تفاجات بوجوده لدرجه ان وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي واف جالانت بنفسه اتى لغزه
لزياره النفق والتجول فيه وعذب نفسه واخذ
كاميرات صورني في النفق ليس هو وحده بل
ايضا متحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي دانييل
غاري دخل النفق وجلب معه الصحافه
العالميه ثم نشروا فيديو قال عثروا عليه
يقولون انه يظهر شقيقا يحيى السنوار يتجول
بسياره داخل النفق لم يذكروا تاريخ
الفيديو طيب هل عثرتم او قبضتم على الشخص
الظاهر في الفيديو طبعا لا ما الفائده من
الفيديو كيف علقتم انتم على هذا الاكتشاف
للجيش الاسرائيلي ابدا بتغريده من عبد
الرحمن من مصر يقول كان في صديق حبيبي
بيتنمر علي عشان انا تخين بيقول احنا لو
نجيبك
هنجيبك غزه هتدخل من نفق السيارات مش من
نفق الافراد ضحكت انا مش عارف بيتكلم عن
ايه الان فهمت عشنا وشفنا نفق السيارات
صالح يقول لك ادعت اسرائيل بانها عثرت على
نفق وهذا امر طبيعي في ظل عملياتها
العسكريه البريه فهي بالنهايه بالنهايه
نافق من مئات الانفاق لكن م لفتني حقا ان
في في في المشاهد التي بثتها المجهودات
التي بذلها شباب المقاومه لبنائه فكيف
بمئات الكيلومترات الاخرى ياسر قال لك
ياسر عثر الاحتلال على نفق المقاومه بطول
4 كيلومترات والسنوار قال له من طول شبكه
الانفاق في غزه 500 كيل متر هذه الانفاق
حفرت بمبل السواعد وكانت هي الشعله في
السابع من اكتوبر نجيد علي قال علي نفق
فاضي ومافيش فيه حد يعني اتقفل ومش مستخدم
ومش متوصل بنفق تاني يعني مافيش شبكه
يعرفوا يكتشفوها ولا
غرقوها على كل حال بعد ساعات من اعلان
الجيش الاسرائيلي اكتشاف هذا النفق الضخم
بطول 4 كيلومترات او عه كيلومترات ردت
كتائب القسام بهذا الفيديو تحت عنوان
وصلتم متاخرين المهمه
انجزت
الله
اكبر رساله القاد العام لقا الضيف هي ما
تمنيت